nous sommes avec thierry lardinoit
médecin généraliste président de la
carmf c'est la caisse autonome de
retraite des médecins de france membre
du collectif laissons les prescrire
syrie ni l'art de noix merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
pour commencer votre réaction peut-être
sur le nombre de contaminations plus de
32000 ce week end
cela peut faire peur mais ça avant tout
finalement parce que nous testons en
masse oui incontestablement
on se rend compte que le nombre de tests
positifs est en augmentation parce que
le nombre de tests est en augmentation
ça ne signifie pas en soi que l'épidémie
soit en explosion complète
j'en veux pour preuve que si on regarde
la mortalité en france entre le début de
l'épidémie la france était quatrième sur
la totalité des pays et où nous sommes
maintenant le neuvième pays en termes de
mortalité
on a donc bien reculer de façon très
importante en termes de mortalité
ce qui prouve bien que l'épidémie est
différente elle est absolument
différente depuis depuis le début donc
oui on teste beaucoup oui on a beaucoup
de positif pour autant on ne voit pas
une explosion comme on l'a vu au mois de
mars et des hospitalisations et des
réanimations et ddb c'est
malheureusement qui peuvent survenir
donc et qui dénie et là on en a la
preuve par tous ces tests
vous parlez d'une épidémie différentes
en quoi ce n'est pas la même pour vous
que la première vague alors là c'est la
façon de la traiter leur aspect il ya
l'aspect que quand on quand on regarde
la les fameuse courbe en cloche
si vous regardez la courbe en cloche de
la première de cette première vague de
cette seule vague en fait c'est une
vraie courbe en cloche qui est
importante avec une ascension brutale du
nombre de morts une ascension brutale
des patients hospitalisés et je rappelle
que cette ascension brutal se produit
sur pratiquement seulement trois grandes
régions 1 c'est pas c'est pas sur
l'ensemble de la france
quand on regarde aujourd'hui l'évolution
des chiffres on est sur la totalité de
la france maintenant il ya plus de
régions qu'ils soient et aimante
épargner toute la france est touchée et
on voit que c'est à temps ses ascensions
étaient très lentes on n'est pas face à
une courbe qui monte brutalement on est
face à une courbe qui monte 12
alors quand on regarde sur les épidémies
d'origine saisonnière et d'origine
pulmonaire on a en ce qui concerne ces
épidémies et je pense particulièrement à
la grippe mais les autres c'est
également un cas ce qu'on appelle des
répliques c'est à dire que dans un
premier temps on voit une grosse
épidémie qui arrive par exemple pour la
grippe on voit ça en descente janvier
et puis vous voyez des petites répliques
en mars avril mai où quelques cas
peuvent apparaître de nouveau j'ai
l'impression j'ai l'impression est bon
je suis pas l'épidémiologiste mais qu'on
est un petit peu sur cette logique là
avec des répliques et sur une sur une
maladie qui incontestablement n'a pas
tout à fait la dangerosité qu'elle avait
à la première phase la politique d'aidé
test pour pour y revenir et ce qu'elle a
progressé selon vous si vous voulez là
vous paraît une voûte dit bien une chose
qui est très intéressant dans votre
propos si vous dites la politique c'est
à dire que s est une décision politique
ou est ce une décision médicale
moi en tant que médecin je ne considère
pas que les tests en en open source en
open bar je dirais un petit peu soit la
meilleure des solutions
mais on peut parfaitement comprendre que
cette décision soit une décision de
nature politique et qu'il était
important pour le politique de faire
cette offre sur le plan médical
épidémiologique sa nécessité
et ça ça comment son utilité me
paraissent un petit peu plus discutable
alors le couvre-feu en tout cas dans les
grandes métropoles a commencé vendredi
soir à minuit quand est-ce qu'on pourra
véritablement observer si là mais la
méthode fonctionne ou pas alors on dit
on dit qu'il ya toujours un décalage
entre alors les indices sept jours les
autres 10 15 jours qu'il ya toujours un
décalage mais habituellement le dirai à
peu près de à peu près de sept jours
pour voir pour voir l'efficacité de
cette méthode sur le terrain comment ça
se passe chez vous docteur comment dans
votre cabinet
vivez cette épidémie est ce que vous
avez un flux permanent de patients
aujourd'hui alors sur le plan pratique
moi je suis dans le grand est
on voit non par un flux permanent mais
on voit arriver quelques quelques cas où
on peut pas le l'on peut pas le
contester
mais qui pour l'instant sont tous plus
tôt plutôt bien que je ne constate pas
de cas graves
je ne constate pas de cadeau alors vous
le disiez vous êtes dans le grand test
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup souffert alors
de la première vague là une région
plutôt épargnée jusqu'ici comment est ce
que vous le comprenez comment est ce que
vous les expliquer alors vous dites
épargné il semblerait qu'on repasse dans
le rouge alors j'ai pas toutes les
explications de ce passage dans le rouge
mouais moi j'ai l'impression que chez
nous la vague a été violent parce qu'on
était les premiers on a été les tout
premiers à subir si vous subir c'est
arrivé donc on n'était peut-être pas
tout à fait tout à fait organiser tout à
fait prêt j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui le tissu médical est un
petit peu plus organisé un petit peu
plus disponibles et on a peut-être un
petit peu tirer les leçons de la
première partie où on avait mis en
retrait la totalité du monde médical il
fallait vraiment que les hôpitaux soient
seul et unique en première ligne façon
on dilue c'est que les autres soient
tous en retrait personne ne veut bouger
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que le monde
médical
tout dans son entier est au travail donc
les médecins généralistes dont je fais
partie mais également tous mes confrères
spécialistes neurologues gastro
entérologue et c'est tout toutes les
professions tous les professionnels de
santé sont au travail face à leurs
patients et que nous prenons en charge
tout ce qu'il est possible de prendre en
charge et que de ce fait la malle sommes
manifestement on réduit ont réduit
l'intensité des l'intensité de la crise
alors une campagne de vaccination contre
la grippe à a débuté la semaine dernière
ce que vous vous constatez une demande
importante de de vaccination ces
derniers jours quel est votre regard sur
sur justement cette stratégie à la
demande de vaccination est absolument
massif massive les les pharmacies sont
totalement dévalisé actuellement il n'y
a pas possibilité de vacciner en ce
moment des gens en dehors de ceux qui
ont reçu les documents de la sécurité
sociale qui leur permettait d'avoir
d'avoir le vaccin gratuitement
donc et du coup ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait craindre une pénurie de vaccins
contre la grippe également
c'est un scénario envisageable non non
ça je ne pense pas moi je donne quitus
quand même aux pouvoirs publics d'être
d'être compétent sur la gestion de ce
type de stocks parce qu'il ya quand même
des habitudes anciennes sur la gestion
de la grippe et ils ont la réflexion qui
est tout à fait logique de privilégier
les populations à risque au premier
temps parce que cette cellule qui risque
d'avoir de gros ennuis si jamais elle
une grille t1 corona donc c'est cela
qu'ils privilégient et c'est cela que
nous privilégions sur le terrain
également
et je pense que ça va très très bien se
passer je pense que ça va très très bien
se passer
alors en amont locaux vides 19 on vit
avec eux jusqu'à l'été prochain au moins
alors on lis pas dans le marc de café
mais moins par essence je suis je suis
une gamme d'optimiste je suis d'une
famille de médecins j'ai la médecine
chevillée au corps moi je suis convaincu
que ressentir des signes de
l'amélioration de la situation et du
fait que nous allons pouvoir venir à
bout de à bout de cette épidémie dans un
délai qui à mon avis est plus
raisonnable que l'été prochain
merci beaucoup thierry lardinoit d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin généraliste et
président de la caisse autonome de
retraite des médecins de france mais
également membre du collectif laissons
les prescrire